in the state of uttarakhand northern
india
a landslide has caused a deluge
it swept away bridges broke dams and
sent a torrent of debris and water
down a mountain valley dozens of bodies
have been recovered here
but the fear is over 100 are still
missing
but what exactly happened here and could
climate change be
to blame for this deadly incident
on sunday 7 february 2021
a landslide at the nanda devi glacier
caused a catastrophic event
a huge wall of water and debris plunged
through the chamoli district of
uttarakhand
northern india high up in the mountains
in nanda devi national park a large
crack had developed
on the side of one of the peaks this
caused an
enormous block of rock and ice to
collapse
into the valley the block was thought to
be over two million cubic meters in size
it fell nearly two kilometers to the
bottom of the valley
where it fragmented on impact and caused
a deluge
and when the flood reached here it
destroyed two dams that were filled with
workers
the flood damaged the rishiganga and
holy ganga hydropower projects
these images show the dam before and
after
part of the site was under construction
so there were workers everywhere
including in tunnels underneath the
plants
the eight metre high tunnel is packed
with debris and slush
and rescuers have been continually
removing earth
since operations began further inside
the tunnel
it gets even more difficult as the
height reduces to 3 meters
restricting bigger machinery hundreds of
people have been brought in for the
rescue efforts
including sniffer dogs digging and
clearing of the debris is taking place
in search of survivors and bodies over
the last 48 hours my boys are involved
all of us are involved we wanted to save
as many lives as we can
and in the bargain if you are able to
recover the dead bodies
it will be good for us workers are
trapped in tunnels like this one
some workers have been lucky enough to
be pulled alive
from the rubble but others were less
fortunate
satinegi and her elder sister have been
keeping a vigil
at the entrance since sunday her 30 year
old brother
was working as a supervisor when the
flood happened
my only brother younger brother we've
been waiting for him for three days now
we are praying that he returns safely
he's got two small daughters and our
mother at home
we have no father he's all that we have
so what exactly caused this if we
observe the
such events over the last two three
decades we can
clearly see the frequency of such events
is increasing in the himalayan region so
we can of course
link this with climate change however i
would stress
right now we we need more data
something similar happened in nepal in
2012
where a landslide caused the sati river
to flood
72 people died one reason behind these
disasters
is rising temperatures which causes the
ice to melt
and destabilizes the landscape and
basically you know it's previously
frozen landscapes
so we call it permafrost where the
grounds continue to be below
zero degrees so as this falls out and
this destabilizes these
steep slates um so you know chunks of
demand
are more likely to break through um but
you know the triggering mechanism of
this event is obviously still under
active investigation and it's
it's always difficult to pinpoint it
down to say this is climate change
these himalayan mountains have been
warming at an alarming rate
rapid large and unchecked construction
has precipitated this even
further affecting the fragile ecosystem
this is a warning which the government
may or may not pay
heed to but it's the vulnerable people
of the mountains
that will bear the brunt